thank you to every single person that
sent me musa mazing flowers kim
kardashian had a low-key birthday
celebration with family on monday night
but it was this family member that made
headlines yeah that seemingly her
brother Rob Kardashian resurfacing on
Instagram for the first time in months I
feel a lot of eyes are on me Kim shared
another video on Instagram where a man
who appears to be robbed can be seen
walking looking noticeably slimmer okay
we can't see his face but we do see what
looks like his tattoos and Chloe posted
this video and someone who sounds like
sister Kylie screams out the father
either way we know Rob is doing good
he's done a good path right now he's
been going through a weight loss journey
Rob's doing great he really is and you
know he's been working out a couple yes
okay he goes to Kim's who's worked out
for like the past five days or so and
he's kicking ass and I just want Rob to
do what's best for him and what makes
him happy and in June a source told et
rob has been taking his health serious
and has been working out and eating
better
he's also focused on family this summer
his ex blac Chyna told ET they moved
past the drama and are working hard at
co-parenting dream who's now two years
old I just felt like having like a good
relationship with the other parent and
co-parents it is like a healthy type of
thing in this something that a lot of
people needs to like practice
[Music]